You have real life
first order abstractions.
If someone's telling you the story
because they're going to tell you
what's the difference between what's
relevant and what is it rather,
why.
You just know when that happens,
you know that the person
is good at telling a story.
So what they're essentially
doing is they're laying
down your experience but not
there's select group about and
that's what needs a boring story.
They do first order,
first order the fictionalization
in some sense they say,
well here's a bunch of interesting
things that happened last week and it was
interesting.
Things have to have some dairies when
your body in some way or you're not going
to find them interesting and have a,
you have to know to extract
something of value at that point,
a point of wind direction
if his suffering.
So that's what makes you,
it's an interesting and
then you might think,
well that's just the boring story coming.
But then you have people who are
brilliant yet say writing novels or we're
producing movies,
screenplays,
and they're way better than a normal
person that extracting what's important,
like the geniuses at it.
And so they don't just
extract that from their life.
What's relevant?
Interesting.
They look at a whole bunch of people and
then how did distilled it into a single
characters and then they extract out
from them what's relevant and interesting
and they lay on this portrayal,
good versus evil and transformation.
It's transfixing.
That's what we do.
We with her religious stories
since the beginning of time,
we'd be watching how we may hate.
We've been extracting the patterns of
that application and we'd been presented
in dramatic form and those stories
are at the bottom of cognitive.
Our church.
That's what are,
it's,
it's within that structure that our
world views rest and that is roughly
speaking,
it's the dreamer.
Good versus evil on the
landscape of chaos versus order.
Order be that place that you're
familiar with and comfortable with.
The home,
the heart,
the family,
that country,
the state,
the well organized community,
the [inaudible] community,
the world's city,
the places that people have always lived.
And then what's the upside of that?
And that's our reality.
That's the landscape.
Within math,
there's a drama group versus evil
and that's our fundamental religious
conception of the world.
And you might take,
well you don't believe in that,
but that's not true.
You do believe in that because
if you didn't believe it,
you wouldn't be human.
Because to human is to live in that world,
metaphysically is very
difficult to say it.
This is reality actually chaos versus
order with the drum out of good and evil
being played down at that.
And that's a very difficult
question to answer,
but one thing I can tell you is that
you act like it is and your brain is
organized like idiots and so that's
pretty powerful evidence that there's
something going on that's vaguely
related to reality and not just to
imagination.
Okay.
I'm going to tell you if you're a
sequence of very old stories and then I'm
going to tell you about Ypo,
related to mass murderers
because I already said that
if you want to answer the
most difficult question,
you have to go with the deepest possible
level and the deepest possible level
isn't what you know.
You know it's what you act out.
And maybe it's what
you start to represent,
but you don't know what it is yet.
It's too profound once to Bizible
in some sense to be part of a fully
articulating knowledge.
One of the things that see wonderful
things that cardio was attempted to do,
I think he was,
I don't know if he was the greatest
thinker of the 20th century,
but he certainly,
he was certainly up there and I'll tell
you what he was up when he took Freud's
idea that you could look at fantasy
and extract out new knowledge,
that idea seriously and then you thought,
well dreams that people
have in your fantasies,
they have our length of mythologies
that they use in their culture.
So the dream is to be individual,
like the myth is to the culture and
you'll believe that we existed within
Stuart's if we'd been,
I've described it.
I think the evidence for that by the way,
is in controvert.
I think Kenny serious psychologist
who knows anything about how the brain
functions in any deep sense is to admit
that the manner in which we construct
the world looks like in heritage now.
And not everyone agrees with that,
but the psychologist that I've come
across who I think are the deepest of the
thinkers have drawn that conclusion and
widely disparate fields ranging from
artificial intelligence
to the analysis of dreams.
It's something that's emerged across this.
So here's where it was up.
The first day he paused what I just
told you about this extension of Freud's
vision of treats.
The second I think there was that are
the way they think about the world is
advantage stories.
Third idea was that the stories were
deeply of who we are and I'm only
culturally but in the deepest possible
biological sense wasn't the mirror
armature,
socio cultural construction.
And I also think the evidence for that
just overwhelming and crystal court,
first of all,
our fundamental biology is very much
like that of the fundamental biology of
animals,
mammals,
social mammals,
the drugs that work on us,
the site,
the drugs that work.
Psychologically,
I'll have to have very similar effects
on animals like rats for example.
We share biological history with animals
and to think about us as some of them
divorced from our biological fundamental
is loosely,
you know that you know,
that might what you don't have to
talk about when you talk to someone,
you don't have to talk
about what anger is.
You don't have to talk
about what theories.
about what jealousy is.
You don't have to talk about what
Hungary's like describe your particular
hunger,
but you don't have to make a
case for the existence of hunger,
right?
There's all these fundamental human
experiences that are part and parcel of
being embodied in the manner that we're
embodied that are beyond discussion
there.
So self-evident pain is one you don't,
you don't have to convince someone else
of the existence of pain or suffering.
I could particularly
alcohol in that regard.
And so we have those fundamental ways
of orienting ourselves to the world that
are deeply rooted biologically.
They manifest themselves in our stories
and that makes up part of our nature.
And we have to figure out how to cope
with those fundamental realities of life.
And the way we do that is by learning to
act in particular ways in the world are
there.
You can strange ways.